m
bien arriver très bien deuxième arrivée
très bien le dernier arrivé très bientôt
et c'est parti pour la première édition
du cross bande d'ados une initiative
signée l'association aide et protection
de l'enfance et de la jeunesse
courir pour le plaisir mais avant tout
courir pour être en bonne santé ils sont
plus de 60 jeunes à prendre le départ
avec pour objectif finir la course
le but
et ça ça idées proposées par nos
éducateurs à l'année dernière c'est dire
essayons de mobiliser le jeune aux
adolescents sur les questions de santé à
ce que cet aperçu qu effectivement on a
des jeunes qui sont insuffisants rénaux
des jeunes obèses et voilà c'est ça a
été un petit peu le point de départ par
la suite
eh ben il nous a semblé opportun de dire
effectivement on peut pas les
sensibiliser seulement leur donnant des
affiches c'est en leur faisant la morale
bien sûr roue libre et c'était de dire
associons à ça une activité sportive
regrouper le monde de la protection de
l'enfance concentrons des associations
qui oeuvrent dans le même secteur une
course entre les jeunes mais également
avec les encadrants sur à peu près 70 à
80 jeunes présents et au niveau
inscriptions nous avons 60 jeunes qui
vont courir
bien évidemment nous avons également les
et les adultes qui ont voulu participer
à cette manifestation pour être aux
côtés de des jeunes donc nous avons à
peu près 80 participants
trois catégories ont pu se distinguer
les 12-14 on les 14 16 ans les plus âgés
faire du sport pour se donner les moyens
de vivre pleinement sa vie c'est aussi
le message qu'a voulu faire passer les
organisateurs en invitant des pointures
du trail locales à courir au côté des
jeunes le sport en fête la maman a reçu
comme le sens de ce cross est un remise
en question au quotidien
le matin au réveil pas où aller
entraîner où tous les joueurs ou entre
un fardeau arrivera pas à certains
niveaux et dans le temps de mener
pareille dans la vie professionnelle
dans la victoire
pareil si ou donne tous les moyens
d'arriver à un objectif
ben on pourra pas réussir à faire les
corrections mal à pratiquer la
compétition des jeunes bien conscient
des bienfaits de la course à pied du
sport en général
présents sur le site le point info santé
du conseil départemental qui a transmis
des conseils précis à ces jeunes qui
parfois oublient l'essentiel était sympa
j'ai bien mais lui s'en tient peu
difficile à les appuyer une santé ça
pour te fait important et une journée
qui s'est terminée par un concert avec
entre autres emilie ivara de manioc
family une bonne ambiance de fête avant
la remise des cadeaux fiscaux
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour deux
à médiation dordé déjà trouvé